- Okay, here we go.
I'm gonna say it is a biscuit.
Ooh, snap, son, that's right.
I'm going to say it is A.
Sweet, I'm good at something.
B, tired.
That don't make no sense.
Toilet?
Nailing it, that's right.
Afternoon?
I'm going to say amazing?
True, true, that's what that meant?
What the who?
Pull the other one?
Asking for another beer?
Beer, did you say?
Alcohol?
Toilets and alcohol, two things I nail.
A, let's go out drinking.
Yeah! Yeah!
A?
Slam.
Acting like I got all these right.
Bloody oath.
Is that, did I do that right?
Amazing, okay cool, true.
I liked the one about the
lizard and the tongue.
I'm busy, or I'm flat out
lying drinking lizard water.
It's like a mouthful.
I'm gonna say that from now
on, that's my new thing.
That's all I'm gonna say from now on.
I love this, this is great.
I'm using all these terms.
Let's go for a maccas run now.
That was good, right?
Was that even, you guys say that?
Is that right?
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
Who told you that one?
- I Googled it.